and we turn to an update on a nightmare
experienced by another community in this
country Parkland Florida in Florida many
relatives of the 17 people murdered at
Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School are
outraged this morning that the killer
will not be executed a jury recommended
instead that Nicholas Cruz a former
student received life in prison without
parole the 24 year old pleaded guilty
last year to plotting and perpetrating
the 2018 shooting murdered 14 students
murdered three staff members as well
Manuel Orca spoke to some of those
families at the courthouse in Fort
Lauderdale that's where we find him this
morning Manny good morning
good morning the jury Foreman says three
of the 12 jurors voted against the death
penalty late last night the prosecution
asked for an investigation saying a
juror reached out to them alleging they
were threatened during the deliberations
but it is unclear whether that can
change the outcome here
this jury failed our families today
following Thursday's verdict distraught
families of the Parkland shootings
victims didn't mince their words I pray
that that animal suffers every day of
his life in jail in Florida a death
sentence requires jurors unanimous
recommendation this jury was divided
citing factors like the defense's
argument that the shooter was mentally
ill in part because of his mother's drug
and alcohol abuse when she was pregnant
victims families couldn't believe it you
have sent the message out there to
everyone you will just get off by
pleading that you're insane
outside the courthouse we followed up
with Linda beagle Shulman her son Scott
beagle was a teacher at the school who
died in the shooting a death penalty for
you would have meant what
a death penalty for me would have meant
that we made sure he was put to death
like he made sure he killed our loved
ones we also spoke with Patricia Oliver
who lost her 17 year old son Joaquin I
feel angry I feel rage
I feel that Justice wasn't served she
told us her husband Manuel decided not
to come to the trial because it would
have been too painful
instead he's traveling across the
country in this school bus emblazoned
with his son's nickname walk to promote
gun violence prevention we the jury CBS
News was with Oliver in Tulsa Oklahoma
as the verdict came down
we had death penalty option
in Florida
and we don't use it when
17 people die through a massacre
inside a school
and that outrage is not just coming from
the Parkland families Florida's governor
called The Verdict a miscarriage of
Justice the judge has set a formal
sentencing to happen on November 1st
Nate
Manny thank you